[Musik]
puh bin ich geschafft vom heutigen tag
bin ich geschafft vom heutigen tag ließ
was ist dann heute passiert dass du so
erledigt bist ließ was ist denn heute
passiert dass du so erledigt best
ich bin heute morgen zur arbeit gegangen
und habe gedacht es wird wieder so ein
08 15 tag und habe gedacht es wird
wieder so ein 08 15 tag
08 was du hast dir bis 17 uhr gearbeitet
nicht bis 15 uhr
08 was du hast ja bis 17 uhr gearbeitet
nein null acht fünfzehn heißt dass es
ein ganz gewöhnlicher tag war
achso komischer ausdruck
08 15
wie dem auch sei wie dem auch sei ich
dachte es wird ein ganz normaler tag ich
dachte es wird ein ganz normaler tag
dann ist bei der arbeit so ein typ
vorbei gekommen der einen strafzettel
bezahlen musste
dann ist bei der arbeit so ein typ
vorbei gekommen der einen strafzettel
bezahlen musste er hat an einer park
verbotszone parkiert und musste um das
schweizer franken bezahlen er hat an
einer park verbotszone parkiert und
musste 100 schweizer franken bezahlen
ich muss zugeben dass er ziemlich gut
aussah
und meine kollegin nadja hat natürlich
ein auge auf ihn geworfen
wie bitte ein auge auf ihn geworfen
das muss ich falsch verstanden haben
wie bitte ein auge auf ihn geworfen dass
er sich falsch verstanden haben
nein matze natürlich nicht ein richtiges
auge nein matze natürlich nicht ein
richtiges auge
wir sagen dass wenn wir uns für jemanden
besonders interessieren
ein auge auf jemanden werfen
ach so dachte ich mir doch dass das
nicht stimmen kann
auf jeden fall ist sie dann auch zum
schalter gekommen
der mann hat das natürlich bemerkt
der mann hat das natürlich bemerkt und
hat sofort damit angefangen ihr honig
ums maul zu schmieren
und hat sofort damit angefangen ihr
honig ums maul zu schmieren
ich geht warum macht ihr denn das ich
geht warum macht ihr denn das nein
natürlich nicht richtigen honig
nein natürlich nicht richtigen honig
das ist eine redewendung und bedeutet
dass man sich bei jemandem
einschmeicheln möchte das ist eine
redewendung und bedeutet dass man sich
bei jemandem einschmeicheln möchte
meistens um etwas von dieser person zu
bekommen
honig ums maul schmieren
ich habe den braten natürlich gerochen
ich habe natürlich gerochen und wusste
dass er einfach den strafzettel nicht
bezahlen wollte und wusste dass er
einfach den strafzettel nicht bezahlen
wollte welcher beraten denn
welcher beraten denn
den braten riechen
deshalb nahm ich nadja zur seite und
sagte ihr deshalb nahm ich nadja zur
seite und sagte ihr dass der mann kein
wirkliches interesse an ihr hat sondern
sie einfach ausnutzen will dass der mann
kein wirkliches interesse an die art
sondern sie einfach ausnutzen will
natürlich habe ich ihr dass durch die
blume gesagt natürlich habe ich ihr dass
durch die blume gesagt hey welche blume
welche blume
puh du verstehst ja wohl gar nichts
durch die blume bedeutet indirekt durch
die blume bedeutet indirekt ich wollte
ihre gefühle nicht verletzen
ich wollte ihre gefühle nicht verletzen
und ihr direkt sagen dass kein mann
wirkliches interesse an ihr haben kann
etwas durch die blume sagen
sie hat das aber nicht verstanden
sie hat das aber nicht verstanden und
hat seinen strafzettel gelöscht und hat
seinen strafzettel gelöscht außerdem hat
sie den nachmittag blau gemacht
außerdem hat sie den nachmittag blau
gemacht
und ist mit ihm in ein super schickes
restaurant gegangen
blaumachen
und was ist dann passiert
ach so und was ist dann passiert
ja was wohl
das was ich erwartet hatte
das was ich erwartet hatte ja ist in
tränen aufgelöst zurückgekommen und hat
erzählt
ja ist in tränen aufgelöst
zurückgekommen und hat erzählt
dass sie ein total schönes date hatte
und der mann sie in ein super schönes
restaurant ausgeführt hatte
danach habe er sich kurz entschuldigt
denn er musste auf die toilette
das problem war allerdings
dass er nie zurückgekommen ist
und sie am ende die teure rechnung
bezahlen musste
als sie die rechnung bekam
ist sie natürlich aus allen wolken
gefallen als sie die rechnung bekam
gefallen
wie bitte aus welchen wolken denn wie
bitte aus welchen wolken denn wieder so
eine redewendung
wieder so eine redewendung das bedeutet
dass sie total überrascht war
das bedeutet dass sie total überrascht
war
ach so klar wie das so eine redewendung
aus allen wolken fallen
sie hat also den ganzen nachmittag
geweint wie ein wasserfall sie hat also
den ganzen nachmittag geweint wie ein
wasserfall ich weiß zwar dass sie nah am
wasser gebaut ist aber soweit
ich weiß zwar dass sie nah am wasser
gebaut ist aber soweit
nah am wasser gebaut nah am wasser
gebaut ach komm jetzt was soll das
wieder heißen ach komm jetzt was soll
das wieder heißen dass sie sehr schnell
und viel weint
dass sie sehr schnell und viel weint
nah am wasser gebaut
aber weißt du was genug von mir aber
weißt du was genug von mir
erzählt von deinem tag
erzähle von deinem tag
mein tag
mein tag war fantastisch
wirklich warum das denn wirklich warum
das denn
weil ich einen neuen freund habe
ich möchte dass du ihn kennen lernst
super
da ist er
das ist marco mein neuer freund lässt
das ist marco mein neuer freund
[Musik]
möchtest du einen kostenlosen online
deutschkurs machen
bei uns kannst du dein deutsch niveau
wählen
so lernst du deutsche lektion für
lektion in der richtigen progression
deutsch lernen mit spaß
besucher jetzt unseren kanal hallo
deutsche schule
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video